i'm not going to tolerate any more of
your crass jokes
your ethnic jokes i'm fully what happens
when you get killed
is you get you get fully enlightened
you're i'm fully [ __ ] woke
yeah yeah giannis went woke yeah so
giannis's brain chemistry has changed
and now he is make
no mistake he's in antifa the
type of jokes that you used that you
well that kitchen triggers me things are
triggering me so now
why does the kitchen trigger you because
i was drinking too much water there oh
you drinking too much water i got
hypotremia and i went to the hospital i
mean
make no mistake johnny had to go to the
hospital because he drank too much water
and had too much diarrhea it's just
he's yawning that's his yawning
stretchers yeah and i had no gatorade
because you [ __ ] dropped it in the
[ __ ] hallway
chrissy you're no help but you did get
me some nice comfy sweatpants i got some
nice coffee sweatpants i mean what can
you do and you're also
skinny mini yanni cuz make no mistake
you're a skinny [ __ ] kid now am i a
hot kid
yeah you know what's really what you
learned
is like when you got covered uh
and it's like you know it's like a
natural it's like a pandemic right
the medical professionals are not kind
to you no they're just kind of like
i'm going like i got a five-week-old
daughter am i gonna live they're going
like
it's a pandemic guy everybody's sick you
know you're like how's your breathing
whatever move you over here you're gonna
be sick for 14 min
this could be three weeks could be three
months could be three years they just
keep you moving yeah
because they're like prioritizing people
who are on
on the you know it's like war time i
imagine that's what like war time was
like like civil war
you came in and you were like my balls
got blown off you're like all right guy
can you walk
yeah yeah well then bite down on this
stick and grab a musk yeah [ __ ] it
florence knight and gail yeah move over
yeah i know but i know it's it's
what i learned is how [ __ ] pussied we
are
yeah this is something that i learned
because covid it kills only like one
percent of the people
right me the media is the enemy so we'll
talk about that in a second yeah
[ __ ] you cuomo the media is really the
enemy no not in that sense but the media
sorry but i mean it's it's like edited
out but this is like oh
you know we we're in a cr this is a war
with a virus yes
and a lot of people have died from this
you know what i mean and so
what i learned is like wow we had it
good
for a way way way way long time yes
cause now we're now you guys need
history hyenas more than ever and guess
what
we need to do this yes and you guys more
than ever
because we're we're we're in for a long
winter baby i mean lucas is getting that
vaccine
but they are not putting a [ __ ]
vaccine in that fat
[ __ ] strong t cell for some reason
immune ass
yeah maybe never cuz you'll get syphilis
before you get you'll get syphilis again
before you
[ __ ] covet i've gotten aids twice and
i still got no cause
you kissed akash on the mouth in the
podcast and you still didn't get it
because
because you [ __ ] andrew santino in the
ass and you still didn't
get it so i don't know why cuz maybe i
don't know i don't know why i didn't get
it
because the night is still young who
knows i mean baby
yeah but the the thing is with this
we're just happy to have you back
cuz because make no mistake we thought
we're gonna lose there for a little
while
i mean yeah you know it's bad you know
it's bad when it's just like
you know you're talking to people and
i'm talking to louis gomez and i mean
i'm trying to get [ __ ] sound
reasoning
advice
listen if this studio's not available
anymore what i would do is bring
hyenas over to gas digital i'll give you
a good split
17 for you yeah 83 for me
yeah yeah it'd be good you got the
studio and guess what you got your
access to jay oaks and whenever you need
them yeah whatever you [ __ ] need and
also slap pockets contests
mma fights all types of gimmicks we can
get to make you
you know we just we replace yachty with
pete lee big
deal what do you think they kind of look
alike kind of look alike
yeah they're both homos yeah one sounds
gay one is
what it is you coin flip guess who we
really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild
[Music]